أخبرنا ديفيد كيف أصبحت
مريضة ،
أعلم أن كلاكما كنت مريضًا وكذلك
ما حدث في صباح الخير في أغسطس ،
نعم ، لقد
تعاقدت مع الطمع في وقت مبكر من شهر يوليو ، ثم
أثناء الاعتناء بي ، انتهى
الأمر
بريسيلا إلى التورط جيدًا أم أه  منتصف شهر يوليو ،
لذا كانت خالية من الحجر الصحي بشأن
أي نهاية يوليو
وأم ولم يكن لدينا أي فكرة أن جيجي كانت
مريضة
آه كما تعلمون بخلاف اليوم السابق لأه
وفاتها ، لقد تقيأت عدة مرات ولكن
مع احتياجاتها الخاصة  ولديها
استسقاء الرأس ، كانت لديها تحويلة ،
لذا اعتقدنا أنه ربما كان
هناك
خلل في التحويلة ، لذلك
أنت تعلم أننا نقلنا لهذا السبب
أخذناها إلى الطبيب عادةً لن
نأخذ أطفالنا إلى الطبيب
للتقيؤ مرتين  ولكن
نظرًا لاحتياجاتها الإضافية ، أردنا
فحصها وكانت تجري في مكتب الطبيب
وكانت تشرب السلاش
، وكانت درجة الحرارة طبيعية ،
وقد أصيبت بطفح جلدي
على كتفها والذي اكتشفناه
لاحقًا  علامة طفل
لم نكن نعرفه
والقيء
هو علامة طفل على مرض كوفيد -19 ، فهو يظهر
بشكل مختلف تمامًا عما يحدث عند البالغين ،
لذلك
من الصعب معرفة ما الذي يجب البحث عنه ،
لذا فإن أي آباء لديهم أطفال
يتقيأون في حالة خمول ولديهم  متسرع ،
إنهم بحاجة للذهاب ،
لذا أنا سعيد جدًا لأنك
تسلط الضوء على ذلك وفي الحقيقة لقد
أرسلت إلينا كل هذه الصور الجميلة لـ
gigi ولكن الصورة التي أرسلتها إلينا
وتريد أن يراها الجميع
هي هذه الصورة  من كتفها هذه هي ،
أعتقد في اليوم السابق أو ربما اليوم الذي
ماتت فيه ويمكنك أن ترى
هذا الطفح الجلدي الصغير فقط أعني أنها
تجلس ويبدو لونها جيدًا تبدو
وكأنها طفلة تبلغ من العمر ست سنوات.  هذا
الطفح الجلدي الذي تريد أن يراه الجميع
، وماذا بعد فترة وجيزة من وفاة بريسيلا
تلك الصورة قبل أربع ساعات من لقائها ،
هذه هي آخر صورة التقطتها
منها
كانت في مكتب الطبيب
وأردت صورة للطفح الجلدي  لقد
أرسلته بالفعل إلى ديفيد وأطلعت
الطبيب عليه
لقد كان كما لو كنت تعلم أن الأطفال يدخلون في الأشياء
التي
يفعلونها وهي تحب اللعب في الخارج وأنت
تعرف
من كان يعلم أنها مجرد واحدة من تلك
الأشياء
التي لن تربطها بالطمع
الآن ، أعتقد أنه
بعد مرور أشهر ، أصبح الناس
يربطونك  تعاملت مع الطفح الجلدي والقيء وعلامات أخرى
مع طفل ،
ولكن في الوقت
الذي قيل لنا فيه إنها مصابة بخلل في المعدة ،
اصطحبها إلى المنزل ودعها تأكل بعض المصاصات
للحصول على قسط من الراحة ، لذلك أخذناها إلى المنزل
وضعناها في قيلولة ،
وذهبت إلى المتجر  أحضر
مصاصات وعدت إلى المنزل إلى
سيارتي إسعاف وسيارات شرطة إطفاء
أمام منزلي وابنتي
مرة أخرى ،
أنا آسف جدًا ، أعني أن هذا أحد
الأشياء المروعة في هذا الأمر هو
كيف حدث ذلك فجأة وداود
فهمت أنه كان واحدًا  من أطفالك الآخرين
الذين عثروا عليها ،
نعم ، لقد عثرت عليها أم تبلغ من العمر 11 عامًا وأخبرتها البالغة من العمر
18 عامًا أنه يعتقد
أنها لا تتنفس
، لذا جاء وبدأ برنامج الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي
اتصل بـ 9-1-1 أم فقط أطفال رائعين
أصبحوا الآن  الاضطرار للذهاب من خلال  gh um
uh مجرد وقت مضطرب
في الحزن والعلاجات
و ptsd um لم يكن بإمكانهم أن يكونوا
أكثر
مثالية في محاولة مساعدة أختهم
وهم مجرد أطفال رائعين